le vatican abrite l'une des plus
importantes communautés gay du monde
c'est ce que soutient mon prochain
invité qui publie le livre sodoma
enquête au coeur du vatican
une brique de 630 et une page dans
laquelle l'auteur décrit tout un système
de camouflage de double vie à la fois
homosexuels et homophobes et de secret
qui ronge et disent catholiques que
vraiment de l'intérieur du plus petit
séminaire jusqu'au vatican tout cela
alors que s'est ouvert aujourd'hui ce
grand sommet sur les abus sexuels mais
attention aux amalgames nous dit
frédéric martel sociologue et auteur
avec qui je me suis entretenu un peu
plus tôt
monsieur martel bonsoir bienvenue à
24,60 depuis paris bonsoir votre livre
sodoma 630 et une page d'une très longue
très longue enquête sur le vatican sur
ce qui se passe au coeur du vatican fait
depuis les petits séminaires jusqu'au
vatican
le titre est so demain et quelle
coïncidence mais vont corriger si ça
sort aujourd'hui alors que ce grand
sommet sur les abus sexuels à rome est
ce une coïncidence
je ne maîtrise pas le calendrier de la
publication vous savez c'est un livre
que j'ai commencé il ya cinq ans et qui
a été très retardé sa vie qui devait
paraître en septembre et qui à cause des
traductions très nombreuses
internationales était retardé sur
janvier février
maintenant pour être honnête avec vous
il est évident qu'il y a des liens et
que pour comprendre cette crise
extrêmement préoccupante du vatican il
faut aussi revenir à cette culture du
secret qui a permis le cover up comme on
dit avec un mauvais anglais sim c'est à
dire la couverture les abus sexuels par
un certain nombre d'évêques de cardinaux
et parfois de prêtres or cette culture
du secret est intrinsèquement liée à
celle que je raconte et c'est pourquoi
au fond la parution aujourd'hui et est
importante parce que ça dit aussi que je
dévoile l'un des secrets de ce sujet
même si bien sûr et je le répète et je
le redirai toujours il y a évidemment
aucun lien entre homosexualité et abus
sexuels puisque les abus sexuels sont
dans la très grande majorité des cas
hétérosexuels ne serait
que parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus
d'hétérosexuels dans le monde que
d'homosexuels mais vous dénoncez dans
cette face cachée de l'église par cette
grande enquête long face cachée c'est
vous-même qui l'employait parce que
cohabitent au fond cette double vie
homosexuelle et en même temps une mobile
radical
c'est intéressant est à la fois
paradoxal non
oui on peut même dire non c'est contre
intuitif en effet mais c'est aussi la
clé en fait pour se cacher les
homosexuels sont homophobes c'est
quelque chose qui est ancien souvenons
nous de over par exemple le l'ancien
patron du fbi qui était lui même une
figure très complexe à un rapport à son
homosexualité est aussi très homophobe
donc c'est quelque chose d'assez
classique mais qui appartient au passé
au fond c'est une homosexualité des
années 50 des années 60 au fond celle de
ses cardinaux qui ont aujourd'hui 80 85
parfois 90 ans et est la clé est
évidemment là il s'agit une culture du
secret qui a privilégié depuis longtemps
un discours très artificielle très
rigide pour casque acier caché
profondément l'homosexualité d'un nombre
très important de cardinaux d'évêques et
de prêtres et ce qui est significatif
dans cette affaire c'est qu'on a à faire
une véritable schizophrénie une
hypocrisie une double vie une sorte de
cette formule que j'aime
particulièrement les rigides qui mène
une double vie
et cette formule et ses mots
schizophrénie hypocrisie ce sont les
formules et les mots du pape prend soin
lui même d'ailleurs
vous l'avez évoqué il ya un instant faut
pas faire de lien bien évidemment entre
l'homosexualité que vous que vous mettez
à jour parce que vous décrivez le
vatican où l'église comme la plus grande
communauté gay dans le monde et la
présence ou ce terreau fertile pour ces
abuseurs ces pédophiles qu'on a caché
mais le pack françois vous dites
entreprend une petite révolution il veut
agir c'est tolérance zéro et à ce titre
vous avez rencontré le cardinal roy
l'aide de québec qui vous a aussi
dépeint un tableau absolument horrible
de ce qui se passe dans l'église de ce
qui s'est passé ou de ce qui se passe
encore peut-être oui en effet j'ai
rencontré marc ouellette j'ai rencontré
aussi plusieurs de ses assistants et
conseillers dont je ne mentionne pas le
nom parce que ils m'ont dévoilé un
charme de choses relativement
intéressante
ce qui est frappant c'est à quel point
l'église catholique est une sorte de
titanic de bateaux qui est en train de
sombrer et dont les objectivement dont
les les acteurs sont au courant et ce
qui est frappant dans cette affaire
c'est combien le pape françois est
attaqué on lui reproche très violemment
d'avoir protégé le cardinal macquarie et
d'avoir protégé des évêques au chili etc
alors qu'il hérite le pape françois
hérite d'une situation profondément
délétère qui provient d'abord et avant
tout des pentifie cas de benoit 16 et
surtout de jean paul ii et il ya donc un
paradoxe à être attaqué par des
cardinaux très homophobe alors même que
ces cardinaux reproche au pape sa son
libéralisme disons un petit peu sur la
question des moeurs alors que même sur
parfois des homos fils ou des
homosexuels pratiquant le cardinal
ouellet est intéressant aussi de ce
point de vue parce que c'est une figure
un peu comment dire
elle a une forme aussi là une forme
aussi de deux doubles discours c'est
plutôt un rating est rien c'est plutôt
quelqu'un qui appartient à la majorité
très conservatrice et en même temps
c'est un ministre entre guillemets du
pape françois et donc il est dans une
situation délicate on l'a vu au moment
du rapport vigano un rapport à la fois
bien informé est totalement je dirais
pas de salle dans ses conclusions
et on a là aussi tout un tas d'effets
très paradoxaux d'une dune curie romaine
et d'un vatican qui est vraiment dans un
état de fuite en avant et de dislocation
un peu abyssal et pourquoi selon vous il
fallait faire sortir du placard cette
homosexualité généralisée à ce moment
c'est en ajoutant et vous l'avez déjà
clarisse seul un gay comme moi pouvait
écrire ce livre
oui parce que cette culture du secret
est à l'origine du cover des abus
sexuels
le lien entre homosexualité abus sexuels
ce n'est pas évidemment par les actes
eux mêmes puisque la grande majorité des
abus sexuels on l'a dit sont
hétérosexuels sont dans les familles
dans les écoles massivement mais il ya
un rapport particulier de l'église à la
couverture de ces abus qui est lié à
l'homosexualité d'un grand nombre de
cardinaux et évêques et donc mon livre
porte sur ça ce n'est pas un livre de
auti que je ne dénonce pas d'aider des
zones sexuelle je n'en sommes pas
quasiment à part certains qui sont morts
depuis longtemps par contre toujours
j'essaye de remonter au système c'est à
dire à une majorité silencieuse je dis
bien une majorité silencieuse qui
comprend essentiellement des homos fil
des homosexuels et parfois aussi des
figures qu'on pourrait dire encore plus
controversée
on avait comparé en terminant tout à
l'heure les ficelles karzaï wallet en
entrevue avec vous qui a comparé les
eaux du panic qui coule alors que les
musiciens continuent de jouer
est-ce que lily est ce que le françois
pourra réussir le pape françois peut
réussir là où on n'a pas eu de volonté
de détermination de faire le ménage
avant mais moi je soutiens enfin très
franchement je soutiens fortement
l'initiative du père françois je pense
qu'il est courageux alors même qu'il est
victime d'une attaque de l'ordre d'un
complot très souvent très hypocrite est
aussi très injuste donc je suis
de son côté et en même temps moi je suis
un chercheur je suis un écrivain
j'ai fait mon travail pendant quatre ans
qui menait une enquête j'ai vécue à rome
j'ai habité dans trois appartements du
vatican j'ai été aussi longuement dans
une trentaine de pays pour mener cette
enquête
et au fond je livre se
lis ce document cet ouvrage et c'est à
l'église à se l'approprier pour faire si
elle le juge utile cette réforme est
aussi au journaliste a enquêté sur cette
double vie encore une fois non pas pour
attaquer des individus ce n'est pas mon
projet mais pour enfants à août et non
pas des hommes mais à ôter un système a
ajouté le vatican comme l'a dit le
journal le point cette semaine à la une
à propos de mon lit en fait à mettre à
jour cette double vie cette hypocrisie
ce mensonge d'état comme vous êtes dans
cet ouvrage de 106 132 pages ça se lit
les pages que j'ai déjà lu se lisent de
manière passionnante intéressante ça
mérite la réflexion ce demain enquête au
coeur du vatican frédéric martel
sociologue chercheur depuis paris merci
au revoir avant